in short subjects a short subject is a
picture that does not run a long time
that is it does not run many minutes a
picture that does not run many weeks is
not called as such a short subject it's
called a bomb yeah but those kind of
pictures don't win Academy Awards oh
they don't know when one of these two
wheelers that are really terrific is
gonna win one right now yes and the
winner is no the nominees oh yeah the
nominees for Best Short subject live are
George Cole Sydney Davis and Anthony
lover producers of the Doug Norman
McLaren for duo John Astin producer of
Prelude and Charles Guggenheim produced
Robert Kennedy remembered and the winner
is
Robert Kennedy remembered
this award belongs in small part to
those of us who produce this picture it
belongs rather in honor of the life of
the man for whom the picture was
produced about tonight you have given
honored to Robert Kennedy
for Best Short subject cartoon the
nominations are the house that Jack
built
wolf Koenig and Jim McKay producers the
magic pea tree
Jimmy Merck my producer windy day John
and Faith Hubley producers and Winnie
the Pooh and the blustery day Walt
Disney producer to help me present the
award we are honored to have a previous
Oscar winner who has always been really
one of my idols when you think of white
tie and Tails savoir-faire pant alike
race who else comes to mind but the one
the only
can't take you anyplace go to your room
yeah get out of here
the winner is Winnie the Pooh and the
blustery day
to us who have worked with wall this is
a very special Oscar and it's a
memorable moment in all of the moments
we've all shared with wall thank you